this video is brought to you by
betterhelp
[Music]
what's up guys michael here with a quick
and dirty take on the latest from the
parker stone brain trust the new south
park special the streaming wars left us
equally delighted and disturbed
delighted because this is some top-notch
south park content i'm gonna go hang out
at tolkien's house for a bit karen
no you're not
yes i am karen you better knock that off
i don't want you playing with tolkien
karen just come back inside and
disturbed because of [ __ ] like this
but beyond that this episode was just
plain clever using unexpected metaphors
to critique two very annoying things one
the proliferation of streaming platforms
and the avalanche of mediocre content
that is wrought we may or may not have
talked about this recently and two
climate change the history of water
commodification and consumption and more
specifically the current droughts in
california and colorado but is there
something deeper going on here are the
platform wars in the water wars
ideologically linked either on or off
screen and most crucially are we all
floating our own crappy little popsicle
stick boats when we engage with global
capitalism let's find out in this
wisecrack quick take will we all be
drinking pee pee soon but before we dive
in we want to thank this video sponsor
better help if you're feeling depressed
anxious or overwhelmed these days better
help can be an excellent resource for
feeling better and i know from personal
experience when you're feeling those
types of things therapy can be a godsend
now betterhelp's network of more than 20
000 therapists are ready to listen to
and help after taking a brief
questionnaire you'll be matched with a
therapist whose expertise fits your
unique needs and what's so cool about a
platform like betterhelp where
everything is done remotely is that you
can work with a therapist whose skills
might not otherwise be available in your
area within 48 hours you can start
messaging with your therapist at any
time and when you do you'll receive
timely and thoughtful responses in
return additionally you can schedule
your choice of secure phone or video
sessions to receive counseling in real
time again like i've said before i
myself have been to therapy i have found
it beyond useful and i just can't urge
you to consider it enough if you're
dealing with things like depression and
anxiety now if you and your therapist
aren't a perfect match it's easy and
free to switch to a new one so join the
more than two million people who have
taken charge of their mental health with
better help by visiting betterhelp.com
wisecrack or just click the link in the
video description when you do you'll get
10 percent off your first month that's
betterhelp.com
wisecrack and now back to the show let's
start with what south park is critiquing
it revolves around a bitter war over
streaming amongst various south park
landowners a couple of small streamers
start out find increased competition and
eventually are basically wiped out by
the largest streamer of all i intend to
be the amazon
river this obviously mirrors the
absolute explosion of streaming
platforms we've seen since netflix moved
beyond dvds in 2007. hulu got big the
following year but netflix set a new
playbook when it started releasing
original content in 2013. competitors
like disney plus would later emerge
proliferating in the form of amazon
prime peacock paramount plus
incidentally south park's new streaming
home and so on the growth of streamers
led to an increasingly ruthless fight to
see who could own our attention and
netflix's recent fall from stock market
grace marks an important turning point
in the streaming wars as chris morangie
of gamco investors explains act 1 was
the land grab phase now we're in the
middle act we see that first act land
grab well underway in this special it's
personified by golf magnate mr kusler
who scrambles to acquire lots of land so
he could catch up on the streaming wars
not unlike what amazon prime did at the
same time the streaming wars in real
life and in south park have brought a
fierce competition to land top tier
talent to produce ever more content and
those proverbial boat builders are left
in the middle just trying to deliver a
good product we're just in the middle
doing our thing sidebar this feels
pretty meta with matt and trey
identifying with the boys as independent
creators in their own crowded and highly
demanding field of content so clearly
the metaphor works but there's also
something really interesting about the
episode's more literal central conflict
the idea of water wars in the american
west especially california isn't just a
tv fantasy you know the show is invoking
the century-old california water horse
from the way the water inspector
character evokes the famous noir
chinatown if that was too subtle for you
there's also some shot for shaq
recreations from the film after all
water has always been a hot and rare
natural commodity in both california and
south park's home state for example back
in 1904 los angeles had the fastest
growing population of any american city
and not nearly enough water to support
its anticipated growth so engineer and
water supervisor william mulholland and
wealthy former mayor fred eaton hatched
a plan to buy land 200 miles north on
the owens river in a region with
plentiful water flow so as not to let
the current residents know what he was
really up to eden lied and claimed he
just wanted to start a cattle ranch and
was able to acquire much of the land
along the river not unlike one golf
magnate oh yes
it looks absolutely ideal when residents
were reluctant to sell eaton lied again
hinting that the government might seize
their property if they didn't comply
meanwhile the owens river area
government was busy planning their own
irrigation project that would serve
hundreds of thousands of acres of local
farmland but eaton eventually bought so
much river adjacent land that this plan
became impossible he sold the land to
l.a county who built an aqueduct that
eventually brought thousands of gallons
of water to the city each year la would
continue to buy more property by the
owens river which saw its once plentiful
land run arid its community collapsed
its farmers ruined its schools closed
and so on a few locals fought back by
bombing the aqueduct and various other
acts of protest but were simply no force
for the city of la the city that birthed
both billy eilish and buffalo chicken
pizza we see a similarly nefarious game
of foot in south park where mr kessler
snatches up all the river adjacent land
in hopes of banking a considerable
profit by selling it to drought
afflicted city dwellers meanwhile back
in real life the california water wars
continue as the wealthy wield their
power to monopolize water flows the
resnicks a powerful billionaire couple
who own huge produce companies in
california currently use more water than
every home in los angeles combined i
hope they're at least well hydrated much
of that water is provided directly by
the country or state via decades-old
contracts and the other nine percent is
purchased on the water market that's a
significant enough amount to drive
prices up making it harder for smaller
farmers to compete what's more the
couple reportedly secured land primed
for water storage via secret meetings
with water officials in the 90s and
they're allowed to store their water and
sell it back to the city in times of
drought this is exactly what we see
happening in this special where folks
fortunate enough to own valuable land
and lots of it are able to profit off a
surrounding drought that's making
everyone else miserable the only
material difference between real life
and the special then is that mr kusler
dies before he gets to become a whole
lot richer in contrast the real-life
resnicks are making bank off their sweet
setup according to research by the
contra costa times from 2000 to 2007 the
resnicks purchased tons of water for
prices as low as 28 per acre foot then
sold of the california for up to
196 dollars these shenanigans earned
them over 30 million dollars all while
the rest of the city suffered in a
drought now that we've set the stage for
the new south park specials focused on
the proliferation of platforms in the
ongoing water wars it's worth asking why
do these make for such an apt metaphor
we think we know why and the answer
leaves us increasingly convinced that
contemporary capitalism has gotten to be
too capitalism-y even for our
libertarian pals matt and trey we'll
explain by its very nature capitalism
demands a limitless economic growth
indeed one study found that a steady
state zero growth economy is simply not
feasible within the social relations of
capitalism as economist william strauss
writes of life under capitalism economic
growth is the bottom line we expect
sustained and continuous growth if an
economy is not growing there's something
wrong with it incidentally every time
someone reads that quote out loud a
little ronald reagan gets its horns and
according to scholar wendy lynn lee in
her book econism profit is not only its
object but its existential condition
commodities form the oxygenating
corpuscles of its bloodstream money the
bone marrow of its ligature hence the
object of every business plan is not
merely growth but to grow the body of
capital forever or die say what you will
about wendy lynn lee but she has bars we
see this mentality at play in this
special when stan and tolkien are asked
to produce ten thousand boats for their
ruthlessly ambitious custler i want ten
thousand of your little boats and i'll
pay you
fifteen thousand dollars they set to
work and somehow managed to reach their
goal but they gotta know popsicle boats
can't scale forever that's because the
mentality of growth runs up against a
very simple reality we live on a finite
planet as lee explains this then is
capital's irresolvable contradiction it
must grow beyond what the planet can
sustain and it cannot do so that the
planet is a found of endless resources
is a myth no future worth wanting can
sustain or even reform its inherently
rapacious conquest for marketable
commodities while the productive
capacity of our planet is limited the
consumptive desires of the homo sapiens
on it are not after world war ii america
sustained its wartime levels of
production which created a problem
businesses needed to generate enough
consumption for everything that was
being made advertising balloon using
tools gleaned from psychoanalysis to
ferment endless desire for consumer
goods or fancy astroturf lawns to
surround your ranch-style house the
consumption spurred on by this process
has since become responsible for over 70
of america's gdp the book affluenza
invites us to contrast that with say
resource scarce 18th century japan
during which a culture of contraction
emphasized quality over quantity and
human knowledge over material things
don't waste resources be grateful and
respectful was the roughly translated
motto the idea of production for
production's sake is all over south
park's critique of the streaming wars
the boys lament that they're just making
stuff to make stuff and witness the
quality of their product diminishing the
more they're forced to scale and cut
corners not unlike the way netflix has
dropped hundreds of films in recent
years most of which are frankly not the
most good and here the party never stops
eventually a sugar high butters wonders
frantically if it even matters what
quality of stuff they produce at all and
they don't give a [ __ ] how good anything
is when the people who made all the
deals they don't give a [ __ ] because
they're all gonna get fired anyway you
know just like production for
production's sake the idea of
consumption for consumption's sake and a
complete disregard for how we use
resources is all over south park in
recent specials the second the water
turns back on we see a wasteful parade
of lawn watering car washing and
sprinkler prancing with valid reason
what about our homeowners association
rules this isn't much of a caricature in
average lifetime each american consumes
40 million gallons of water for personal
industrial and agricultural purposes
researchers mathis whackernagel and
william reese determined that if all
people live like the average american
we'd need five more planets meanwhile
the demand for even more boats is akin
to our demand for ever more streaming
content to consume and one of the grand
promises of capitalism is just that
endless variety endless consumer choice
endless ways to consume but as our
friend pp quickly learns endless
consumer choices may be more dizzying
and annoying than anything else infinite
options like infinite streaming
platforms to pay 10 bucks a month for
might not be that desirable after all
there's a too many streaming services
there's a streaming service for this and
a streaming service for that
peepee came to find his staffer so where
are we left in our world of
overproduction and over consumption
according to lee nowhere good she writes
that conquest capital devours and
digests values ethical civic and
aesthetic reducing each to that single
value without which it can either
replicate itself nor grow exchange in so
doing it generates a state of affairs
that can only rightfully be described as
pathologically nihilistic again she has
bars according to philosopher elon baju
nihilism is fittingly that murderous
avatar of desire for the west meaning
that when capitalism erodes all values
and aren't connected with profit and
consumption we end up in a culture of
nihilism where nothing means anything
except the bottom line that's certainly
what stan's thinking when he quickly
agrees to kessler's deal despite
probably knowing that it's not in the
best economic interest of his family
when we have no tangible values beyond
the logic of capital we're left in
pretty grim straits at the same time we
know we're using up our planet's finite
resources yet we can't stop pursuing
constant growth in this way according to
lee capitalism destroys its own
existential conditions through the
wholesale commodification of the finite
ecosystems upon which it depends i.e
capitalism sets the ladder it's using to
get to heaven on fire in the scramble
for south park's water these landowners
aren't fixing any long-term problems
caused by global man-bearing they're
merely capitalizing off of a resource
shortage that's been caused by big
industry in the first place they don't
see this crisis as a crisis but has an
opportunity if we wanted to depress you
we'd mention that this is happening in
real life scholar mackenzie funk
documents the rise of private business
finding ways to profit from our
dramatically changing planet in his book
windfall the booming business of global
warming that's right corporations have
destroyed the earth and now they're
going to make bank off of it see also
our video on carbon capture in which a
stanford scientist explains how
companies are making profits off our
climate disaster take water which is
going to become an increasingly valuable
commodity conservative economists are
already proposing the creation of a more
robust water market that relies on well
pure market rules rather than continuing
to have the state or federal governments
subsidize it this is enticing to
investors as citigroup's chief economist
says water as an asset class will in my
view become eventually the single most
important physical commodity-based asset
class dwarfing oil among other valuable
commodities the very wealthy are already
investing in and water-based hedge funds
like summit global management are
pouring billions of dollars into it as
they also buy up billions of gallons of
river water and other privatized water
utilities as they plan for a future
where we're all really [ __ ] thirsty
as historian mark reisner puts it water
flows up hill to money this approach
profiting off of an ecological crisis is
exemplified in the presumably pasta
loving character of pee-pee the
amusement park owner knows very well
that man bear pig will get him one day
but gleefully points out man pig
eventually
he's gonna kill everybody
he's just gonna kill you first and the
nihilism of unchecked capitalism there's
no truth behind your bottom line and
there's nothing else to do but
accumulate more wealth and when all the
water is gone
there's only one thing left for people
to use
the one thing that a pee-pee have more
than everybody huh and wait for the day
man bear pigs send you out for one final
ride down the water slide unless of
course you're eric carpenter don't worry
we didn't forget about him carmen's
tireless desire for something cool to
happen also makes him something like the
id of capitalism in his longing to
upgrade his life by moving into
kessler's mansion he tries to convince
his mom to get just just stupidly big
breast implants this is not unlike the
way so many advertisements target
women's bodily insecurities convincing
them they're just one brazilian butt
lift away from the life they dream of
and if cartman is pure unbridled
capitalism cartman's mom functions as a
kind of avatar for the american consumer
who's determined not to get swindled or
outsmarted again and as a sign perhaps
that there might be hope for south park
and for all of us she gets the best of
cartman this time at least for now and
cartman for his part ends up with
massive boobs cause you gotta commit to
the bid but what do you guys think are
matt and trey becoming increasingly
skeptical of capitalism the richer they
get are we capable of thinking about
anything outside of a framework of
profit and the accumulation of wealth or
is everything just royally [ __ ] let us
know in the comments huge thanks to our
patrons for all your support and check
out our revamped patreon page today and
be sure to check out our new stream
wisecrack live right here every thursday
at 11am pacific maul that subscribe
button like you're a man bear pig
disemboweling a water supervisor and
don't forget to ring that bell and as
always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you